le monde du paratennis de table était à
50 ans en Yveline pendant 4 jours le
vélodrome national a accueilli plus de
260 parapongistes venus de 40 pays à
l'occasion du Sky par tt ce rendez-vous
était organisé pour la deuxième fois
dans la structure au programme des
centaines de matchs avec 22 classes de
handicap 11 pour les hommes et 11 pour
les femmes cette compétition c'est l'une
des plus grosses compétitions de l'année
c'est aussi enfin c'est même plus dur
que les championnats du monde de l'année
dernière parce que déjà il y avait pas
les Chinois l'année dernière cette année
ils sont venus à trois par catégorie
minimum mais ça fait du bien de voir un
tel niveau dans une compétition et voir
vraiment ce qu'on vaut sur le plan
sportif ce rendez-vous labéisé par la
Fédération internationale était
qualificatif pour Paris 2024 ils sont
tous là pour ça en fait voilà on a eu
des matchs très tendus puisque c'était
des points àer chercher c'est les
derniers points de 2023 ceux qui
réussissent à gagner des points sur ce
tournoi là peuvent être tranquilles pour
la fin de la qualification par contre
les autres doivent rentrer doivent
continuer à faire des des tournois un
rêve pour beaucoup de sportifs du 78
dans les iines luci Autier Julien Michot
y Adjal espè faire partie de l'aventure
pour les Jeux Olympiques on est tous un
peu dans les starting B pour les jeux
donc ici tout le monde vient pour
maximiser les points on a beaucoup de
Français sur la liste en liste d'attente
il beaucoup de concurrents mais on est
là on est là et puis on verra bien dans
quelques mois mais au final comme je te
dis sans pression je fais un petit
bonhomme de chemin j'avance je me rends
compte que faut aller step by step au
tableau des médailles la Chine termine
première avec 38 médailles dont 15 en or
la France est au pied du podium à la 4e
place avec 10 médailles dont de en or